tu-16 area code new collar new topic two
one six go ahead hey David thanks for
taking the call I'd like to maybe let a
problem and just get your question or
lay it out and get your thoughts on it
your mom
I think representation is kind of a big
one that I just don't hear spoken about
it enough and so maybe let's just let me
lay it out here real quick because the
electoral colleges which is kind of this
check on the states and kind of our
executive branch to elect the president
but the biggest check on the president
is the House of Representatives which is
again a state appointed or district body
but the problem for me is the lack of
representation in the house I think
we're third worst in the developed world
behind China and India in terms of
proportional representation and the lack
of voting district you know
gerrymandering and things like that so
it kind of hurts like you can't really
have a functional democracy without
proper representation and to how you get
your representative so you know the
first-past-the-post and then you know
changing to like a sort of a state
proportional representation we just
don't have enough groups that are why
don't we have a libertarian wing of the
Republican Party because there's not
enough representatives and how they're
voted on okay let me let me see if we
can do a little bit and see if I know
what you're saying when you say that we
have poor representation in the House of
Representatives do you mean that the
number of people represented by each
elected official is too high being
700,000 or whatever or do you mean that
the proportion yeah okay Hardee's boat
doesn't that good so proportion of
political ideology in the public yes
both actually both okay yeah I mean I
think both are issues both they're
definitely issues so let's deal with
them one at a time one is if you think
there should be more than 435 elected
official of members of the House of
Representatives so that each represents
fewer people there is a mechanism to do
that in fact it sort of lines up with
what what one of David Farris strategies
was in his book we interviewed him
earlier in the week about how Democrats
should play dirty and and one of the
things they should do is both increase
the number of state
so that there are more senators and try
to get more elected officials in the
House of Representatives the second
issue is an issue that is just it's
inherent to the system that we have
which is if 5% of the population in all
congressional elections votes for
libertarians but we end up with 0%
libertarians in the House of
Representatives is that really fair and
the answer is it depends what you mean
by fair and under our current system it
is considered fair because it is as you
mentioned to first-past-the-post you get
one winner and that's it other countries
have decided it differently and I've
spoken before about how I would be
interested in exploring ways that we
could do something like that in the u.s.
of course the problem becomes that then
when the white supremacists get 5
percent of the vote in a bunch of
different races not enough to win any
race now you've got 5% white
supremacists in the House of
Representative and do you want that but
you're identifying two very real
problems for sure yeah well I you know I
appreciate your insight on that and it's
something that I just don't hear spoken
about and you know there's all these
great ideas that academia has to solve a
lot of these problems and I you know
it's surprising to me how you know it's
like policy is this emergent phenomenon
where these great ideas are filtered
through the raw absolutely wrong kind of
people but I kind of put that on we're
electing these career politicians
instead of a bunch of Representatives of
ideas and ideology you know I think yeah
misconstrue what a politician a
politician is a representative of a
community not necessarily the greatest
policymaker know they're going to filter
an idea there were certain lens of
ideology whether people like that or not
that's just what we need and in order to
get that you really need to work with
good smart intellectual people who can
actually craft the policy that matches
the ideology of the collective group I
would love to see that and I don't think
we're gonna see it anytime soon
unfortunately I really appreciate the
call you're making really good points
and I hope to hear from you again